like mh370 and in the southern Indian
Ocean madam Speaker we mourn all those
239 passengers and crew I know words
which can ease that be
people want answers to what's happened
no everyone's going to want closure Mrs
E analyzed the images and in what area
of the ocean measure some 400 square
kilometers
it is 18 days since Malaysian Airlines
flight mh370 disappeared on its fateful
journey from Kuala Lumpur to Beijing and
after 24 hours grounded by the weather
the international search fleet resumed
its mission by air and at sea as 12
planes and five ships combed the
southern Indian Ocean southwest of
Australia satellite images yielded
another potential clue in the hunt
yesterday undertook a favor much the
Malaysian remote sensing agency mr si
receive new satellite images from Airbus
defensible space which is based in
France and these images were taken on
the finger mrca analyzed the images and
in one area of the ocean measure some
400 square kilometers were able to
identify 122 financial objects some
objects were returning others for as
much as 23 meters some of them
definitely grind possibly indicating
these new images to the untrained eye
little more than flex barely visible
between the clouds may prove the most
important sighting yet they follow
previous notable satellite images that
have overtime help narrow the boundaries
of a vast search area the search of the
southern Indian Ocean began over a week
ago on March the 18th day by day it has
been refined as aircraft of Criss
crossed the ocean today focused on these
areas in the south of the surf zone
now attention turns to the new potential
debris field here it's close to the area
of previous sightings from Chinese and
Australian aircraft
during the weather delay the search team
has grown Japanese and Chinese planes
and ships have joined the effort
suspending regional differences to work
together the search is being
co-ordinated by australia the skies
James Matthews has joined one of the
aircraft's at the heart of the recovery
yet well I'm in the cockpits of an
Australian Orion p3 being flown by
flying officer captain Peter Moore and
11 squadron crew 3 take a look at this
cockpit normally not as busy as it is
right now normally three people in here
there are five sets of eyes looking
around scanning the Vista what this
aircraft is doing is one of a dozen in
use today this is flying in a series of
straight lines effectively up and down a
grid covering 900 square miles in the
search for the debris the remnants of
mh370 two of the search stores that we
carry on the aircraft we have a passive
sauna boy the idea of this for this sort
of mission we fire this out of the
aircraft we can use it a market position
because it actually sends out an hour in
signal that other aircraft can home too
but it also it has a hydrophone set up
one cable we can set this at different
depths we're going quite because the
ward round here is extremely
and these things have a drogue chute on
them so they're affected more by that
the drift in the ocean so it's the water
drift so when we're looking to submerge
debris this sort of thing will have the
same sort of drift rate is what the
debris will have so will give us a
better idea the other third store we use
the side a tomboy so these are the same
thing they have a UHF uplink other
aircraft and search ass heads can home
to them we freefall these out of the
aircraft and these are affected more by
wind so if we're looking for people in
the water this is the sort of thing that
will drop because they tend to match the
way of human being will drift in the
water as opposed to debris which musa
sadr boarding school well they were a
bit further back on this planet the
navigation communication and tactical
stations you can see it's still very
much eyes on through the dorm dwindle
looking down from a height of around 700
feet we have been down to 650 and as
high as 800 some other aircraft go as
low as 200 feet but this crew have phone
during for sorties that 700 feet works
for them gives them a an appropriate
visual corn from that height but it can
look down and they have a reasonable
sized vista to scan the surface and just
beneath the surface let me show you
something interesting if you look this
way this engine this plane has four
engines for propeller engines one has
been switched off to maximize the amount
of time you can stay in the search area
by saving fuel
this orion is just one of the assets in
the multinational search team Sky's
David Boden and our experts look at how
they work together we can see how they
work in the search zones they're making
sure that no part of this vast area is
missed as they hunt for this wreckage
which may vary in size from many meters
to tiny smallish chunks how difficult is
it to get hold of the smaller pieces and
put them together and realize that this
is all part of the same plane given that
we know there's lots of junk in this
ocean as well yeah there's not likely to
be a typical aircraft accident into the
water there's not likely to be a very
high proportion of the stuff that floats
so they're going to have random bits a
lot of composite structure plastic
stretcher so it's not going to be
possible to put that stuff together I
mean you would clearly look for
interesting features on it such as
burning which might suggest an in-flight
fire or blast damage high explosives but
presumably the key to all of this is
this is all well and good but until
somebody gets a chunk any chunk onto a
ship analyzes it and says yes this is
mh370 we're still in the dark could be
anything yes exactly yes yes and the
main value of it as david says we'll be
tracking back to try to discover where
stuff is on the seabed and how does the
search pattern actually work I mean
they're the planes and the ship just do
their own thing or do we have planes
going in one direction ships in the
other almost like a grid sequence I
don't know the details of it the normal
thing would be a a sort of lawn mower
pattern moment and mowing the grass so
just backwards and forwards either on
the surface or in the air and presumably
that is to ensure in this vast ocean
that we don't miss an entire corridor
where all the plane is yeah that's right
and it's relatively simple to do that
these days with global positioning
system okay well let's have a look at
some of the assets that are involved in
this we talked about ships and planes
we've got hm SAS success that's the
Australian Navy ship that's been there
one of what we now know are two main
search areas the other half of the
Seaborn effort at the moment is a
Chinese ship HMS echoes also on her way
she's been refueling in the Maldives
she's part of the Navy's survey flotilla
and there's a detector and American
towed pinger locator an instrument that
can help find a black box that system
will be fitted onto a ship and it will
be towed out into the search area and
there's also this robotic mini sub
called the bluefin now that can go all
the way down to four and a half thousand
meters and examine in detail what's
going on below the ocean the sunset on
another fruitless day at sea with the
families of the 239 passengers and crew
no closer to understanding how and why
flight mh370 crashed anger at the
official response saw them take to the
streets in Beijing on Tuesday they
marched on the malaysian embassy target
for the frustration and grievance of the
bereaved today they got a response the
delegation from Malaysia flew in to
brief the families okay go g3t know that
there's a boat anything else ever be for
the degree are they're grieving in
Australia too madam Speaker we mourn all
those 239 passengers and crew Australia
will do all it can to recover what we
can from the southern India nation so
that they can have the closure and
eventually the peace that comes with
understanding more of what happened
it was another reminder that above all
search for flight mh370 is about people
in part 2 we look at the human cost of
the tragedy and the technology involved
in the recovery effort
you
like mh370 and in the southern Indian
Ocean madam Speaker we mourn all those
239 passengers and crew no words which
can use that thing people want answers
to what's happened nope everyone's going
to want closer mr ACA analyze images and
in one area of the ocean depression some
400 square kilometers for able to
identify 102
today's developments with now for
satellite images to work from narrowed
the search area in the southern Indian
Ocean skies David Bowden has analysis
from the Situation Room if we zoom into
that search area 1,500 miles or so south
west of Perth in the southern Indian
Ocean the search for mh370 resume this
morning after gale force winds and heavy
swells suspended it yesterday and as you
can see by the colors marked on here
these are the areas they've already been
searched starting all the way back to
March the 18th today we've got 12
aircraft joining the search seven
military and five civil planes together
with a number of ships now the search
area has now been condensed to 50,000
square miles it's still huge but it's
getting more clearly defined every day
and by the time they reach the site the
aircraft only have enough fuel for about
two hours of search time before they
need to go back to Perth so that's the
search area that's what's going on
gentlemen has experienced investigators
now Alice of this Tony do you feel that
their zoning in now on the real deal
this is debris from the plane it's
starting to look like it but there's not
going to be a definite until some of
that wreckage is retrieved and he's
identified as being part of the trip or
seven because we've heard that a French
satellite has found what might be a
fairly contained debris field with
hundreds of articles in it but it's all
over an area of about 160 square miles
which sounds a lot but in this ocean is
actually quite tight yes I mean debris
released from an aircraft meeting the
water is going to disperse naturally
because it will be differently affected
by the wind and the current depending on
how high it's floating above the surface
so things will disperse a bit even if
they start off in the same place daddy
just let me ask you as a sort of
overview
how do you view the way the search is
going now do you think this is the
beginning of the end game and they are
going to come up with the real deal here
well I think it does point towards us
having located the debris field
hopefully that's the case and then the
search will get more refined on that
debris field but then of course it'll
have to expand because that debris field
will have floated for some considerable
distance and so then we have to work
back and find the initial impact points
and hope you find the flight data
recorders there but so we could be
seeing a widening of that search area
again after that all right well we're
positing there for now let's have a look
at who's doing what as far as the search
is concerned we've got six countries
assisting the search-and-rescue
operation at the moment there's a new
zealand air force p3 Orion that's been
over the area Australia's also got two
of its own p threes in the search and
the largest ship in the area hmas
success there's a Chinese aircraft and
for Chinese ships also in the search
area already and the United States Navy
have got their p8 Poseidon submarine
detector also in there there r p3
Orion's from Japan and South Korea as
well and five civil aircraft also part
of the search with volunteers on board
to act as lookouts so finally gentlemen
it looks as though we're getting all the
resource necessary to make this happen
they're saturating the area both from
the sky and on the sea and presumably
it's only a matter of time but if I
stalk to you David we were speaking last
week about data recorders the clock is
ticking big time on this because he's
only got 30 days and we're what 17 18
days into it absolutely the race is on
to find those the the pinger on the
flight data recorder and cockpit voice
recorders should last at least 30 days
so we may have a little bit more time
than that so but certainly the effort
will be to get equipment down there that
can actually hear the pins that the
flight data recorders will be sending
out
challenge now is to locate that flight
data recorder under the ocean it calls
for a highly specialized skilled
operation you really need to be very
very close to that acoustic pinner to be
able to hear it to give you an example
if we're talking 4,000 meters of water
you know you can't be on the surface and
hear it you need to be you know a few
hundred meters away and possibly you
know a few hundred meters to either side
no more than 1,500 2,000 meters beyond
that you probably won't hear it skies
Amanda Walker has more on the underwater
technology that will be deployed if
anything can find flight mh370 s black
box it's this a state-of-the-art
hydrophone deployed with the US Navy to
help solve the agonizing mystery this is
the crucial noise that everyone wants it
to detect the pings emitted by a black
box we are very optimistic that the
equipment can do the work it just
depends on how much time we have to do
it bad weather makes the operation go
much much longer the depth should not be
a problem here the topography should not
be a problem it can track the pings made
by a data recorder from up to around for
miles underwater flight mh370 spins are
expected to fall silent in around two
weeks time the pinger has approximately
a 30-day battery life it's like if you
have a flashlight you keep it on it'll
slowly get dimmer and dimmer until it
wouldn't come on anymore it's the same
with the pinger
but if time does run out all might not
be lost Phoenix International assisted
with the recovery effort of the Air
France plane that went down in the
Atlantic five years ago the black box
ping was never heard but this equipment
help them find it anyway this remotely
operated vehicle can function up to four
miles down it's equipped with like sonar
and cameras and it's those arms that
would ultimately recover a black box but
no one is doubting the mammoth scale of
this task the authorities know how many
hopes are pinned to this technology and
the chance that it could lead to at
least some answers but so many are so
desperately seeking question of why the
aircraft went down is still unanswered
and may prove as challenging as the
search early suspicion fell on the
flights captain fifty-three-year-old
zahari ahmed shark he's a vastly
experienced pilot in multan 18 and a
half thousand flying hours under his
belt the first officer was Fariq Abdul
Hamid 27 and joined Malaysian Airlines
in 2007 it was fairly new to this model
of aircraft a Boeing triple7 200
this CCTV shows the two men going
through security on their way to board
the flight that evening we're told they
did not specifically request to fly
together
police started searching their homes
talking to friends and neighbors they
found this flight simulator in captain
zaharie house investigators say that
some data on it has been deleted could
the flight manifest hold the answers
investigators are scrutinizing all 239
names
more than two weeks after the planes
disappearance were still learning more
about the men women and children who
were on board this flight chandrika
Sharma was heading to Mongolia via
Beijing to attend a United Nations
meeting on food and agriculture her
husband and daughter are inconsolable
the youngest passenger on the flight two
years old the oldest 76 seven of them
were children he'll never reach their
fifth birthdays twenty-six-year-old you
wen Chou is originally from Mongolia we
moved to study business at whole
University in England gone home to see
his girlfriend
mukesh mukajee and his wife sie mal x
had been on a beach holiday together in
Vietnam the two young sons were waiting
for the home
15 different nationalities were flying
to Beijing that night among them 153
from China 38 from Malaysia 5 Indians
for French 3 from the United States to
Iranian Zhan bored became initial
suspects but seemed to have been ruled
out 35 year old Joo Koon is a stuntman
and was due to start work on a new
series for netflix in Malaysia next week
he was on his way to Beijing sees two
children Bob and Cathy lorton from
springfield lakes in Australia they have
three daughters described as doting
grandparents Paul weeks is a mechanical
engineer he accidentally left his
wedding ring and watch behind him at
home when he traveled to Mongolia for
work hadrian wat r a loss on the right
in 17 Xiao Yan on the left 18 they were
on their way to school in Beijing
at every turn the mystery of mh370 is
defied simple explanation
I hope for all the search crews at work
over these vast expanses of ocean is
that they can recover pieces of the Lost
plane finally provide proof of its fate
for the waiting relatives
what we're trying to do is is at least
provide evidence of where the aircraft
aircraft may have gone down and at 5.45
by purely doing that we're providing at
least some closer to the to the family
and friends of those on board for the
grieving families can't come soon enough
you